let's start with something you may have  seen before the diet coke and mentos  explosion this works because of a  property called nucleation the Mentos  candy has a very high surface area  filled with microscopic dimples when  it's dropped into the soda  each of these dimples called a  nucleation site releases a tiny co2  molecule the result is explosive baking  soda has a compound called sodium  bicarbonate when it's combined with an  acid like vinegar it forms an unstable  compound that explosively decomposes  into carbon dioxide  when certain elements like boron are  burned their electrons become energized  and give off light as they lose energy  cornstarch is a very fine powder it  won't burn well by itself but when it's  turned into an aerosol and a funnel it  will explode waste and age  this stump remover contains potassium  nitrate a powerful oxidizing agent that  will help the sugar burn releasing an  explosive cloud of smoke  that's you explode